foreign
[Music]
Wade I am a senior Cloud solution
architect for Microsoft specializing in
data in AI I'm here to present to you
a topic covering the r integration in
power bi and why you as our developers
should be interested
I am very passionate about both R and
power bi so much so that I wrote a book
about it I understand that many art
developers do not share the same passion
about power bi that I do many of you all
may be saying why should I even be
interested in our integration in power
bi the reason why is because the power
bi Community needs you
so before I get into the
meat of this talk I want you all to know
what this talk is not about
this talk is not about me trying to
convince you to replace your assignee
apps with power bi
you are able to do things in shiny from
our visual standpoint that you can't do
in power bi and I'm not trying to
convince you to make that switch
I am not trying to convince you to
refactor the notebooks that you develop
in Jupiter notebooks are markdown or
Quattro and replace that with power bi
those two different tools or those tools
have a different purpose than what power
bi have
so I would not try to convince you to
make that change and also I'm not going
to tell you to say and I'm not going to
tell you to start doing your art
development in power bi
and ditch our studio I am not trying to
convince you to do that microphone
Microsoft is not trying to convince you
to do that either Microsoft gives you
the option to do your development in our
studio when you're doing when you're
writing code that is a purpose for power
bi so that is what the talk is not about
where the talk is about is to address
the disconnect between between uh some
art developers and part bi developers
both sides have their own perception of
what the other tool is and often that
perception is not correct so we're going
to address that
I'm also going going to try to introduce
power bi to
some our developers that is not familiar
with the tool you probably heard of it
but you probably never really seen it in
an action so I'm going to try to
introduce it to you and give you a high
level understanding of what power bi is
and then I'll give you some examples of
the integration so that you can say wow
Ryan was able to do these things in
power bi based off of how I'll say he's
using the functionality maybe I can do
these other things that Ryan hasn't
thought of
and then Lastly lastly I will show you
how to get started
so first let's address some of the the
disconnect there are a lot of unknown
unknowns that our developers have about
power bi and that power bi developers
have about
um r
from a r standpoint when our developers
look at Power bi they just see another
GUI based data visualization tool
power bi is much more than that and in
this talk I will show you the reason
behind that
and then on the power bi side when the
property I developers look at R they see
a the main specific programming language
they think is just for data scientists
and statisticians
they don't realize that a lot of the
things that power bi attempts to do have
been done in our community for some time
now since the 90s I think our was
developed in the early 90s like 93 so
the our community has been doing things
from a data visualization standpoint
that power bi that the power bi
Community had just recently started
doing so we will address that
um well that's on on the other side when
I'm doing different types of talk I try
to tell the power bi Community some of
the things that you can do using that
tool that they're not aware of
so now that I got that address of
Disconnect let's let me introduce
power bi to some of you that are new to
it from a high level
Barbie I is a data visualization tool so
in order to do data visualization data
visualization you need data and the data
model that power bi prefer is a data
model known as the star schema data
model
the starter schema data model is made up
of two types of tables a dimension table
and a fat table the fat table you see
here in the center and the fat Table
stores measures you can think of a
measure some that measures and a
business uh activity in this particular
simple example we see that the measures
are price and quantity
and then the fat table is connected to
the dimension table and then the
dimension tables you have
Dimensions Group by category so you see
in this particular example we have a
store Dimension a uh employee Dimension
and so on and so forth you can read the
screen and those different categories
you you have Dimensions that you can
group your your measures in your fat
table by
another thing I want to point out about
power bi from a data standpoint is how
the data is stored in power bi power bi
uses an engine called the vertipack
engine and the takeaway I want you to
get from that is that the vertapac
engine one stores the data in memory
using what is called column store
indexing
and the takeaway you should get is that
storing data in that fashion does two
things it makes performance you know
some complex calculation relatively
faster than you will then then what it
will perform if you're using another
tool and in addition to that the column
store index and increases the memory
footprint of your data by a lot in some
cases up to a tenth of the size of the
original data set
so the second thing I want to point out
is the built-in data Wrangler tool
that's in power bi and this built-in
data Wrangler tool if you are using
Microsoft Excel this tool is built into
that as well this is like a a gym that
many people don't know about this tool
is called Power query and this tool
using a GUI allows you to do many types
of data Wrangler attacks with low code
super easy a person who has no coding
experience can do a lot of complex data
wrangling that we in our community will
probably have to write a deployment a d
ply R script to do with no code and then
in the instances where you need to use
code it has a programming language
underneath the hood called M that you
can write some code to do some you know
things that you can't do throughout the
GUI
super powerful and again it's built in
in the Microsoft Excel so it's a tool
you should look into if you're doing any
type of data wrangling in Microsoft
Excel as well
and this is what the interface look like
and you'll see that the interface is
similar to some of the office other
Office Products so the learning curve uh
with uh getting up to speed with this
particular tool is uh pretty shallow
the feature that I like the best about
micro about uh Power bi are the
calculated measures calculate what I
like about calculated measures is the
way they operate inside of power bi they
are what I call a contest based meaning
that they calculate based off of the
context that you put them in so in this
particular situation we have a simple uh
Matrix where we have uh where we're
displaying three different
measures and those measures are the
sales amount uh calculated measures and
those are the sales amount calculated
measure the comparison cells amount
calculate calculated measure and
adjusted comparison cells amount
calculated measure
one thing I want to point out is that we
look at the highlighted cell
in that cell
the comparison sales amount calculated
measure is calculated in the context of
the adventure work brand and also the
context of the comparison date filter
that you see in the slide filter in on
the upper right portion of the screen
notice I didn't mention the filter that
was being applied by the other day
slicer and I only mentioned a slice on
the right that is because the
programming language that power bi uses
a programming language is called that's
data analysis expression uh programming
language it allows you to incorporate
some pretty sophisticated business logic
inside of it and in this particular
situation you
can see that we were able to remove the
filter from the from one of the slices
and we only kept the filter that was
apply and the uh slices in the upper
right super powerful feature you will be
surprised at the type of business logic
that you can encapsulate inside of a Dax
expression using power bi
and then of course it's a data
visualization tool so just like any
other data visual data visualization
tool whether you're talking about uh
Power bi click that below I know we have
a speaker talking about that particular
tool you can build dashboards and get as
RC as you want you know you can get real
pretty I'm not good at that aspect you
know I do everything pretty blind but if
you're a very colorful person you can do
that or you can pretty much do any type
of visual you want in a power bi just
like you can't win any other
visualization tool
now up to this point you may be saying
Ryan you just describe a pretty awesome
tool why do we even need the r
integration inside of power bi how do we
even benefit from this well this is my
opinion this little graph right here uh
this is my opinionated view about
um you know how I think power bi is this
is my assessment of power bi using these
four different categories and in these
four different categories you see in
most of the categories I uh
thing power bi is a very awesome tool
other than the data science modeling
piece
it does a good job of data visualization
data wrangling for the most part for
most situations and then from a
context-based calculation that I showed
you earlier that feature right there in
power bi is awesome now the data science
modeling side of things is very limited
and that you normally would need the
premium capacity version of power bi to
be able to leverage uh Azure machine
learning services and you can do some
data modeling there and then a connect
to power bi from there or you can use
some pre-built data models in the form
of
Azure cognitive services
so from that standpoint still it's kind
of clunky as I don't really recommend it
but when you add R to the situation
you'll see that from a data events
there'll be in in not 80 to 5 80 to 90
percent of the time you have a visual
that's already baked into Power bi order
you can get from the Microsoft store to
import it into Power bi but there would
be those edge cases where if you are
used to coding and ggplot you can you
know create that visual easily in GG
plot but you can't do a Microsoft that
is what that orange is representing and
then on the daily wrangling side there
are situations where you may need a
regular expression to do uh some type of
a screen manipulation or you may need to
do something that is pretty clunky to do
in power bi but you can easily do it in
D Fly R and and those situations is
represented by the orange there and then
on the data model aside if you're doing
something in data science where you want
to bring in score data into your power
bi data model uh if you're using power
bi in a self-service fashion you can
take those R scripts that you have that
will you know will ingest in data scored
and you can take that score data and
easily adjust into Power bi and that's
why I added that little orange for the
data science modeling piece
so now let's talk about some examples
the first example is a very simple data
science uh machine learning example
using a data set that
if you were you know learning any type
of data science you're probably familiar
with this data set the Boston Housing uh
data set and it's very simple
illustration of how you can take a model
that was saved in the RDS file on disk
consume that model and then consume the
data that you need for the scorn and
just like you do in any other situation
with our you can use that model and the
the new data that you want to score
scored and then present that data to
power bi as a data set if you had a a
more complex
um
uh workflow you you all that went to the
tiny Workshop here or if you're if
you're familiar with tidy models you can
use tidy models if you have a more
sophisticated workflow that you need to
do prior to scoring the data
uh once you score that data the caveat
is that that data set needs to be
exposed as a data frame if this is
exposed as a data frame then you can
bring into Power bi if you have it in
any other data structure or less
probably I would not be able to read it
another aspect that I like when using R
the r integration and power bi is if I
need to read a data from a data API in
this particular example I'm reading data
from the U.S census
and I can I can easily consume data from
a data API using R from a power query
standpoint they have some integration
but it's very concrete and it's not as
performant as using R so in this
situation I'm looking at I'm integrating
the census API bringing in data and
exposing that data to a power bi and
you'll see that it will be it's supposed
to probably as a data set that can be
extremely value valuable when you're
using outside data to bring more value
to the data that you have in-house
now the thing I like the best is the
data visualization piece in terms of our
integration in this example this visual
is near to me this is the uh visual
where I was uh
it was the first visual I built when
this when the r integration became
available in power bi and in this
situation you'll see that we are able to
do things with r that we're spoiled but
the power bi Community don't even know
of some of these capabilities one of
those capabilities is the ability to
have annotations inside of your graph
now in this particular graph if you were
to add up all the different classes
you'll see that those uh the numbers
don't add to the to the total number of
countries the 235 countries and I'm able
to add information in my title about why
that's the case for each individual
violin plot that's overlaid with a box
plot I'm able to give information about
that the number of countries that was in
that particular course class and the
trade balance for that particular class
those type of annotations in the power
bi Community they're not aware of and
that's those were one of the things that
make it super powerful another thing is
if you want to choose another year
you'll see that I can easily pick a
button and then that filter will be
propagated to my art Visual and if I
wanted to look at this and I say okay
looking over to the left hand side and I
see that the Caribbeans for instance we
have a positive trade experience with
the Caribbeans if you look at the uh
left hand side I can drill down further
into the information and get detailed
information using the power bi
functionality so
this our Visual and and if we're on the
on the our side we're used to be able to
be this expressive with our visuals but
not on the power bi side and you as our
developers should reach out to some of
your
uh people in the power bi community and
you know teach them how the our
integration can be super beneficial to
them I gave you some examples here but
there are many more examples that once
you start digging into it you'll be able
to find out more examples and in your
unique use cases you can use also to be
creative with using that our integration
inside of power bi
um that's the end of this presentation
if you want you can go to this GitHub
site and I have a little GitHub
um repo that gives you some high level
information about leveraging the our
integration inside of power bi
um I appreciate you all coming to the
talk and listen to me tell you about
this art integration and I hope you go
out and spread the love of the our
community to other power bi developers
and show them why we love the great
programming language of our thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]